Moving from the flight to the landing — for landing it's important that beforehand
we've already worked out which direction we'll fly the landing circuit, right or left,
and above all it's important that everybody follows the same rules.
Because in the landing phase we're not far from the ground, which means we have
little or no time left to react.
Up at 1,000 metres above the ground, when something goes wrong, you can take your time
looking at the terrain and reacting. But near the landing site everything happens
much faster, simply because the ground is right there.
So the basic principle has to be that we all fly the same landing circuit, and that way
we can guarantee that we can see what the others ahead of us are doing.
The landing circuit works like this — we decide on a left-hand or right-hand circuit
and then we head to the positioning leg and into the descending circle,
which is where we lose height before entering a proper landing circuit.
And in that descending circle it's important to fly three correct, full circles.
If it's a right circuit, you fly right circles; if it's a left circuit, you fly left circles.
Then we end up at a sensible height for the landing circuit.
We teach that height during your training. After one, two, three landings
you can roughly hit the upwind leg. It varies, depending on the air mass,
on where you are — it doesn't have to be the same every time.
It can be completely different once wind is involved.
That's why it's important to develop a feel for it, and to trust that feel.
It takes everyone two, three, four flights before they get a handle on it,
and that's exactly why your instructor is with you on the radio.
I'm letting you know that very quickly you'll get the hang of it,
and after a couple of guided flights you can do it independently.
Upwind leg, crosswind leg, downwind — sorry, final leg.
When we notice we're on the upwind leg, we need clearly enough height.
Then we can comfortably turn into the crosswind leg,
and we can also extend the crosswind leg
if we have the room — fly out wider and round the corner.
If we're too short, we won't notice it quite as much,
and I can shorten it very simply, as shown here.
Or we can fly the crosswind leg with S-turns,
always following the correct reference points.
And the great thing about those S-turns is that at any moment
we can leave the crosswind leg and head into the final whenever it suits us.
On final, just fly straight.
We can make small course corrections ourselves
if there's a bit of sidewind, but ultimately the important thing
is to fly the target accurately.
If we notice we're far too high,
there are several options.
We can, for example, make ourselves big.
That means the pilot and the wing create relatively a lot of drag,
and when we sit back in the harness,
we glide well and have little drag.
Or we make ourselves bigger by sitting up out of the harness,
make sure the landing gear — your legs — is ready,
and then we generate a lot of drag,
which means we have a worse glide.
Put differently, we can lose height efficiently.
And that's how we get to our landing point.
The other option is, very gently, S-turns.
Those are allowed, too. Or, if we get there later,
with little-ears.
We pull little-ears in — simply put, the wing becomes smaller,
we sink faster, and that also gives us a better chance
of landing on the spot.
The briefing for us is that in a 30-metre circle,
if we touch down inside that circle,
we've nailed a great landing.
Important: if we have to pull little-ears,
be aware that
in that configuration we can't steer the wing very much.
I can steer with weight-shift,
but my freedom of movement is restricted,
and we need to bear that in mind.
So it's better to have the little-ears in already,
rather than doing something unconsidered or in a panic,
which usually doesn't go well.
Then there are still situations
where the landing turns out a bit differently than we'd planned,
than we'd had in mind.
For example, we've flown a landing circuit.
We had a headwind originally,
which is always nice — that lets us land into wind,
the way we normally do.
Now we suddenly have a tailwind,
because the wind has shifted.
That's not a drama.
What's important is that we follow through with the landing circuit
once we've committed to it,
and we just deal with landing in the tailwind.
With a tailwind we have more groundspeed in the final.
That means we have to apply the brakes faster,
more effectively,
than we're used to on a normal landing.
On a normal landing we go to
the brakes slowly until we're just gliding above the ground.
Landing in tailwind we need to flare crisply
and decisively brake,
to build up the momentum
where the wing stops above us and right then both feet hit the ground.
Even in tailwind you can make a clean, soft landing.
A tailwind landing is no drama, it's just a skill
you can practise.
I'm not talking about 30 km/h tailwind, of course,
but 5 to 10 km/h,
which is something you can manage.
It can also happen that we have to do an out-landing.
The reason might be that the landing site is closed,
and we have no other option.
For an out-landing, it's important not to,
if there's a slope, not to fly into the slope.
If we're on a slope we don't fly directly into the hillside on flare,
but we land parallel to the slope.
There we make exactly the same kind of landing,
touching down parallel to the slope.
Good — done and dusted.
Now it can also happen that we've misjudged things
and we've overshot the landing site,
and we end up at a car park where cars are parked.
Whatever it is, there's a difference
between flying onto it at 30 km/h
and landing at only 5 km/h, or even 0,
and that way we can still land on it.
So to avoid a collision,
the idea is to bleed off energy and not just stay up there and shout,
and do nothing.
Then we shouldn't worry about people watching us,
or care about being in an embarrassing situation.
It can happen. We've done something wrong,
we can't reach the landing site anymore, and we end up landing on the way to it.
Then there's the tree-landing chapter,
but I've already chosen something better,
because a tree landing is even worse.
If you can choose, prefer the alternative to a tree,
since then I'd have a better chance,
of getting away with bumps and the like. The important thing in flight
is to bleed off energy, via the brakes,
and to protect the head — keep your head away from the branches.
Important: there's good documentation about tree rescues.
The same pilot is usually very safe in flight,
with a lot of lines and fabric around them.
The same is true for a reserve descent over a forest —
there's a lot of fabric, a lot of line.
It catches in the branches; very rarely or never does it happen
that the pilot falls through the trees to the ground.
Usually they stay hanging up there, and that's fundamentally safe.
Most accidents that happen in this situation
come from people going into shock.
When they're in shock, clearly an emergency situation,
they try to free themselves and end up falling.
Because for example you might be hanging in a tree on a steep slope
and the slope to the side is right there,
and it looks like only two metres,
but people don't notice that on the tree side
they might be 15 metres up.
And if you unclip from the harness and fall,
15 metres is absolutely devastating.
So important: if this happens,
fundamentally, stay calm first.
Calm, calm, calm, and then take your time and say,
right, analyse the situation.
The smartest move, if you're in fairly civilised terrain,
is to inform the emergency services anyway.
REGA, the Swiss air rescue, can be reached almost anywhere
and they're glad to hear from you.
They're glad to know
where you are, whether you're OK,
and whether you need help.
In my view, you need help
any time you notice that
you're stuck in a tree,
and higher than one or two metres.
Call REGA,
and getting yourself and the wing recovered with their help
is much easier.
Rather than risking a fall —
as we said,
falling from height.
So basically — let people know what's going on,
and then wait for help.
It takes patience.
In our region we're very lucky.
A few times with REGA,
they're very quick,
and so we can say
the rescue is set in motion very quickly.
Another landing situation,
which hopefully you never encounter,
and that's why it's flagged,
is a water landing.
Water landings have to be avoided,
because still water in winter
can be very, very cold,
and with your hands you can quickly get cold and stiff,
and become unable
to swim.
Even worse is in a river.
A river current is a trap.
It's pretty uncontrollable,
I'd say,
it can be that...
If at all possible,
if I see
I'm going to end up in water,
open the harness early,
so that when you actually touch the water,
you can immediately swim away from the gear.
But it's important,
never before touching the water,
to step out of the harness,
because in the shock of the moment,
with all the gear,
if they're...
we don't have it under control,
and now we're five metres
above the water and we jump,
or we're at 20 metres,
and that can also have very serious consequences
if you misjudge it.
(unclear)
You have to try
to make it here,
whether the intermediate stages get taken care of.
You don't have much time
to do it,
and then you grab on.
It's already there,
I have to think now,
it's up to you,
have a look for yourself,
even when I do,
what I'm at now in the other river,
you have to push again,
yes,
have a look there.
If the whole landing business doesn't quite go to plan,
or if someone has a landing that doesn't go quite as nicely as the K-shaped final flare
and they get injured, it's also important that we know how to look after an injured pilot.
With paragliding we unfortunately have one disadvantage: we're in a sitting position,
meaning that if we come down hard, we're sitting,
and it goes pretty directly into the spine.
That's why spinal injuries in paragliding are not uncommon.
And when we reach the injured pilot, it's really important to know that.
It means we have to calm them down first, and then we'll fairly quickly notice how badly
or where the pilot is hurt.
If it's the back and breathing still works fine,
the best thing is to leave them lying down and immediately inform REGA
so they can come in with the helicopter and pick them up.
When the helicopter comes, it's important to know it kicks up a lot of wind.
As soon as it lands — meaning, get everything packed up, maybe your harness,
maybe your wing, all the loose gear,
stash it under a stone or something so nothing flies off into the rotors and endangers the helicopter.
When the injury is to the back, it's important
that if the pilot wants to sit up or drink something — that's a normal reaction,
after an accident — we have to prevent that.
We have to stay still, not move, as long as they're responsive.
And also nothing to drink — that's also important,
because we don't know if they have internal injuries or not.
Now, now we move on to the topic of flight technique. The point is
that we should know what our wing can actually do,
or it's important what we can influence
to make the wing glide better or sink less.
And here it's quite simple — you can see it on this scale —
that with a school wing,
we get our best glide — meaning we travel from point A to point B with the most efficiency —
when we have about 5 to 15 cm of brake contact.
At that speed, we stay in the air as long as possible.
That's the minimum sink in the scale.
We don't travel the furthest,
but per unit of time we stay aloft longest.
Pulling a bit more brake, around 15-20 cm,
we're a bit above trim speed.
And as we approach minimum airspeed —
the slowest the paraglider will still fly,
before it really stalls,
which we'll come to later —
minimum airspeed is always with relatively strong brake input.
We can really pull the brakes down,
but important: keep your elbows pointing nicely forward.
And then we're at about 40 cm,
where we're already flying pretty slowly.
The opposite we can also do,
namely accelerate,
when we use the speedbar,
or in most cases,
we can push it through,
and then we pick up a lot of speed,
because we're doing nothing other
than reducing our angle of attack,
so we go faster,
and so the wing inherently flies faster.
The accelerator, very simply put,
we always use whenever we have a headwind.
So fundamentally,
we then play the brakes back and forth — (long stutter, omitted)
the wings ahead on the landing site,
or wherever we can still reach another landing spot.
Then there's not only flying itself with take-off and landing.
We've talked about it already, but it should be fun too.
There's also so-called soaring.
When you can use ridge lift,
we call that soaring.
When the broader wind
flows up the slope,
there's a band of lift.
And in that lift band you can climb
to higher altitudes.
And it's not that hard.
It's mostly wind-driven.
There are also thermals,
but you don't want to confuse it with thermals.
Let's stick to soaring for now.
There it's important,
as a beginner, to keep distance from the slope,
distance from the slope,
and once again, distance from the slope.
Why?
Because we're constantly gliding.
There might be other airspace users,
who also fly in that area
and create wake turbulence
with their aircraft.
And if you get drawn into one
of those things quickly,
or there can simply be more wind,
and you get pushed more towards the slope,
you have to be able to react
to fly away from the slope again.
And in general, always turn away from the slope.
Not towards it,
because then we have a tailwind component on the slope.
The sink rate of the turn itself
is hard to estimate.
And if you head into the slope with a tailwind component,
that's not good.
So the things to bear in mind for soaring,
always pay very close attention to them.
Now we have,
depending on the area,
naturally thermal flying.
And thermal flying
is probably
the supreme discipline
of paragliding.
We want to fly as far as possible.
That means we use thermals
as a means of transport.
Because if you just glide,
we only have our glide performance.
If we launch from say 1,000 metres,
we can glide about 8 kilometres.
But now we have thermals.
That means
I have to know
how to read those thermals
and how I can fly them —
thermal flying.
To fly thermals,
I need to know a few basic rules.
The easiest, of course,
is when we have visual feedback from the clouds —
we see the thermal optically.
Then we simply fly in that direction.
Let's take an example with a cloud.
If there's no wind,
it's relatively easy
to find the core.
Just fly straight at the cloud.
And once we've found the core relatively quickly,
hopefully we climb.
The whole thing gets harder when there's wind.
Let's take an example here:
the wind is coming from the left.
The clouds drift like this.
That means
with the wing I have to fly to the upwind side
of the cloud,
so that I climb up nicely in the core
while drifting with the wind.
And that's how you exploit a thermal optimally.
All of this is relatively easy to look at in the flatlands.
It gets harder
when you're in proper mountains
where there are steep rock faces,
because the thermals are sharp,
they release very quickly.
That means
it's not broad,
but compact,
and correspondingly more turbulent.
That's good
if you can climb very fast
in very tight circles,
but for beginners
that quickly leads to overload.
What's important in thermals
is to sit nice and loose,
to do a lot with weight-shift.
On the one hand,
to centre the thermal nicely,
but also very importantly,
when you steer with weight,
many pilots
do that way too little,
and they rely too heavily on the brakes,
and too little on weight-shift.
Really important —
when you're sure
that the next point
you'd planned for
you'll definitely reach.
There's nothing worse
than ditching a thermal early
and then not making it to the next mountain
low down,
where you expect the next thermal.
It's really important
to thermal it out,
and that takes a lot of patience,
to get the height
to safely reach the next planned
point,
where you assume
the next thermal
will be
and lift you up again.
All of this takes extreme amounts of experience,
and at the start, be happy
if in the flatlands,
you can centre a thermal,
climb up nicely and calmly,
enjoy that,
and the success will come with experience.
In thermal flying,
we can also
encounter situations
you'd rather not be in,
namely a wing behaviour
we're not used to.
There can be collapses,
there can be frontal collapses,
which we'll now take up under the topic of big-ears.
Excuse me.
Pulling big-ears
is a flight manoeuvre.
When you take the SHV's
brevet exam,
the brevet-relevant manoeuvres
are
the ones beautifully
explained by video,
because for the brevet,
you have to be able to fly
certain manoeuvres.
We'll start with little-ears,
which we've already heard about
during the landing.
Little-ears is nothing more than
the outermost lines
of each side —
it's the outermost A-line,
not to be confused with the stabilo line.
The stabilo line is on the outside
of the paraglider,
usually colour-coded,
separate and very thin.
But it's the outermost A-line
that we use to inflate the wing on launch.
On some
wing models it's separated, on some it's bundled together.
And it's always the outermost A-line,
left and right,
and then we pull our little-ears.
We collapse the tips and we can wonderfully
practise — with weight-shift
we can still steer the wing.
Little-ears, as I said,
for example when you have a high-altitude landing
and need to come down a bit faster —
great manoeuvre —
or if you simply want more sink
to generate,
to get to know the wing,
doing little-ears
is absolutely a good manoeuvre,
it really is.
There are also big-ears.
Then depending on the wing model,
we take not just the outermost A-line,
but the second outermost A-line as well,
when you have one over there.
And then we can fold in much more of the ears.
Really important: there are also wings
that have only two attachment points.
And there you're not allowed to pull both in
at the same time,
or you get a frontal collapse.
Otherwise we do nothing different
from little-ears as I described,
and for big-ears,
we then take the hand from the inside
and bend down,
so we get about 15 or 20 more centimetres of line,
and then we pull them in.
For big-ears.
Really important with big-ears,
to simultaneously,
as you're pulling the lines in,
accelerate.
Because only then
can we prevent
us from pulling in too much ear,
too much drag,
the wing flies slowly
and then truly stalls.
By accelerating,
by pushing the bar, by pulling the lines,
and now together,
the wing is once again
flying at a normal angle,
despite the extra drag
from the ears being pulled.
Afterwards, to open the ears,
just let go.
Only when the ears are completely open
do you come off the speedbar.
Again here,
if we pull the ears in,
let go, come off the bar —
if you come off the accelerator,
we still have a lot of drag,
and the wing flies slowly
and by coming off the bar,
it can be
that we then go directly into a true stall,
which can happen,
and we want to prevent that.
A stall is nothing other
than that we fly too slowly.
Our wing's flying speed,
the forward airspeed,
we've fallen below it.
It tips,
essentially backwards,
and totally
empties from the wing.
There's a pre-stage,
the parachutal stall,
the wing is still inflated.
We have no forward speed anymore,
and we only have sink,
and you sense it through the wing,
that there's no forward speed,
it feels strange.
The wing is mushy,
then we're flying slowly,
and we've got the brakes there again.
Or flying with a really wet wing,
it can happen
that we go into a parachutal stall.
Then fundamentally it's important,
we're flying slowly,
what helps,
is the move from slow to fast,
we need to speed up.
That means,
immediately grab the A-risers
and push,
so that it picks up speed,
or use the accelerator,
as it were,
the whole accelerator,
we want to get back
into normal position,
so that we have speed on the wing
and come out of the stall.
What can also happen,
in thermal flying,
is that as we fly,
we get hit by wind shear
and the wing collapses
up to 50%.
Completely out of nowhere.
You get a real shock at first.
That's normal at the start,
but here too
it's important
that we react, and react actively.
If we do nothing,
what happens is,
after the collapse the wing
will have extremely high drag.
And it will turn to the side
of the wing
where the collapse happened.
With a few hundred metres of altitude
things can quickly turn bad.
That's why it's important
that we react quickly.
Whether it's a collapse or a stall
is the same.
When a collapse happens,
the basic principle has to be:
weight-shift to the open side,
lightly brake against the turn.
Brake, if necessary,
so that we can keep flying straight
and then the basic principle is to stabilise
and then react.
Then we can deal with the collapse
to reopen it.
When we
do descent manoeuvres,
I mean,
we have to come down quickly,
because for example
the weather is changing.
We say,
we don't want to be flying so long,
the weather is moving in.
It can also be
that it makes sense
to know certain descent manoeuvres.
Big-ears,
which we talked about already,
that's very important
and a good descent manoeuvre,
as with big-ears,
you can still steer with weight
and fly forward.
So that means,
if we're in a strong band of lift,
fly away from the lift band,
and don't stay inside it.
The B-stall,
which is also described
and which the brevet asks about,
has a big disadvantage:
that we do it here,
and although we generate a lot of sink,
we can't steer at all,
but,
I mean,
if we're in a band of lift,
in strong lift,
we're still stuck inside.
And as soon as we're out,
we fly out.
B-stall is nothing more
than that we take,
sit there,
not the A-risers,
but the B-risers,
the B-risers,
and slowly pull them down to us.
Important is
that we have the brakes,
totally normally in hand,
not actually wrapped,
we just pull them down at the same time.
Otherwise it's...
B-risers,
the B-risers,
to pull down.
And then there's a fold in the lower sail,
and noticeably, then only sink.
And you can sit comfortably in the harness,
hold it,
with me in training,
or under guidance from a flight instructor on the radio.
We've practised that well.
Afterwards,
to release the B-stall,
it's nothing more
than at first
slowly,
and then completely,
on the four,
and also on the four,
and on the four,
and on the four.
And then there's 4,000 kilos.
And not everyone handles that.
And that's why it's important
to do some really solid training,
in a safe,
guided SIV course,
or there's also the option
of the G-Force Trainer,
which wonderfully,
in a simulator,
lets me
get to know myself,
how I react
in a spiral dive.
Stuff like that.
The new manoeuvre,
which the touring brevet now requires,
but is still worth mentioning,
is
that you essentially do a spiral dive
with a held collapse.
That's the first one,
as already discussed.
And then you do
on the opposite side,
the so-called wing-spiral.
It has an advantage:
you generate a lot of sink,
but have less G-load.
We're back into the G-forces
and how it presents itself.
It's also a manoeuvre
that belongs in an SIV,
but important
that you've heard of it.
What might come up in the theory test
is the spin,
the twist,
as well as wingovers.
And you need to know
what that is.
Spin is nothing other
than one side being
pulled too far down.
For example,
as in a spiral exit,
but done totally motor-skill style.
And then the airspeed disappears
and the wing rotates negatively.
That's a spin.
If you can do this very quickly,
it can be
that the wing rotates above,
and we below,
have the momentum,
where the wing first follows with too little speed.
I can ride this out of the wing's shoulder
and find myself
in this position from the start.
And then I can imagine,
these wire braids,
happens really quickly,
the wing makes a bit of a back-shoot.
And now I have a twist.
That means,
nothing other than,
the risers got twisted up.
Then I'm in a twist.
That's the term for it.
When I...
How do we fly wingovers?
It's nothing other than
getting the wing to roll.
That means,
I choose
a free side,
left or right,
and apply weight and brake to that side.
And as soon as I'm back
below in the pendulum,
I already release on the opposite side,
the brake input.
Crazy stuff!
Where it looks Gold and Spezler-style
and later also with brake-input timing.
Just the brake-input dosing
happens.
Then the brake input comes onto the brake input.
Then come the certain brake inputs.
Then come the
people,
the people, the people, the people, the people.
Eye-stunts, you just notice,
you have to get to know your wing and train.
The same is nothing other than
that we strongly brake the wing standing still.
Wing goes behind.
More than a person for us, and now we wait,
until the wing once again hundreds.
Before, wait until the lower stage.
Now we want to brake again.
There it is mostly very common danger, that people already
while descending start braking again,
and so the wing stops,
but if we really wait in the lower stage,
until we're a bit past the lowest point,
and then we brake again.
That's not a path we get for free.
There they want to see in the brevet,
that it pendulums up to the trailing and leading edge.
It's not the craziest climb, but still,
we have to work the wing,
and that's a goal,
so that we can get to know the whole thing.
Now, the manoeuvres,
like wingover and so on,
it can all be a lot of fun
and makes total sense
to train.
But it can also always happen
that the whole thing goes pear-shaped.
And the topic of the reserve parachute,
the next chapter looks ahead,
always and forever,
you must know,
your reserve parachute doesn't have anything to do (with luck).
It's absolutely useless if you have a reserve
and you don't pull it.
And the very, very important principle —
skydivers have a system
where, when they have a certain time
or a certain altitude they've passed,
an automatic reserve is deployed.
Most paragliders don't have that,
and by design
there's never been a really clean solution found.
That means
in an emergency situation, more than ever as a pilot,
actively pull the reserve parachute.
And only if you don't pull,
it'll never work.
We need to be very, very aware of that.
When we have the situation,
loss of control,
and we do nothing,
and the situation doesn't improve.
First try to improve it,
and if you say, OK this isn't working.
Now I can't control it,
now I have to my reserve
grab and pull.
When you pull the reserve,
the basic principle
is always: when it's uncontrollable.
Meaning a state
where I don't know which way is up or down,
and a state
you can't within a very short time,
we say three seconds,
two-to-three seconds, stabilise,
and get back into normal flight,
it's time for the reserve.
I've got the whole thing at low altitude,
meaning I'm in the descent,
in the landing area,
and yes, I'm low.
And I have a problem.
Immediately pull the reserve.
Loss of control,
I don't know what the wing is doing,
immediately pull the reserve.
That can happen out of a cravat, for example.
It can happen that you have two collapses,
if we planned a frill-based manoeuvre,
something uncontrolled, immediately reserve.
It can also be
that there's a mid-air collision,
because it's running again.
We have relatively a lot of airspace,
but other airspace users too,
and if we have a mid-air,
then it's safer right away
to pull the reserve parachute.
We know, even
if we'd go from the mid-air and fly on,
we know that the aircraft is so heavily damaged
that perhaps exactly in the worst moment,
say in the final approach,
we can't,
react and pull the reserve.
So in a mid-air,
if we still have flight
over a large salt flat — pull the reserve,
even if it seems controllable,
the first basic principle applies again.
There's no thinking about it — pull the reserve immediately.
It can also be
that there's a medical issue.
Your flight is out,
and your vision goes black.
No matter what, it's not OK.
Then the reserve is the best option,
rather than somewhere uncontrolled,
wandering into terrain,
with the paraglider.
Not a good option.
What also nowadays very rarely
happens, almost never anymore,
is material failure,
but it could happen,
that something does break.
In thinking about the harness, it's something like,
like a seam,
and the flight has been ended,
that you can come down
at an angle,
because something's torn,
then it's certainly out of the topic,
go for the reserve.
The basic principle
of the second chance,
when something's uncontrollable,
that we don't see the second chance,
the reserve,
is really, really important
for the whole flying journey.
I say with that,
where it's a second chance,
when you have to hand
and mouth know,
how it works,
the whole system.
How it works,
we absolutely have to ask through the flight school
still,
I'd like that,
for the students in Zurich,
that they know
where the reserve handle is,
a good habit, too,
for example,
if you do a normal flight check
with the flat of your hand on every flight,
where you touch,
where the reserve is,
so that in an emergency
you also know,
how to react.
The reserve is a big topic.
There are still things to discuss,
like how often to repack it.
Some manufacturers
say,
every 6 months a fresh repack.
Practice shows,
every 6 months to once a year.
Anything beyond that you don't really want,
packed longer than a year,
rather it should be refolded.
That's a big topic
and a course in itself.
What we've covered here
in flight practice,
is that
which is asked at the brevet,
I know,
and I hope
you enjoyed the talk.
I thank you very much
for your attention
and see you soon.